In Ukraine tonight, brutal fighting
along the front lines as Kiev's
counteroffensive grinds out.
Hard fought
gains against heavily fortified
Russian positions in Ukraine.
Russian airstrikes
and artillery attacks
are going
on, reportedly
slowing the Ukrainian advance,
at least for now.
Our senior international correspondent
Fred Pleitgen is joining us
with all the latest from the war zone.
Ukraine's army continuing
to take the fight to the Russians
on the southern front.
This video shows the 128th
territorial defense
battalion clearing
trenches after ousting
Vladimir Putin's army.
The unit says
one of the soldiers nicknamed the octopus
telling me the fighting remains fierce.
Adjust. They just.
We're currently launching an assault,
he says.
Our front line is moving forward.
We've already advanced
a lot more than two kilometers.
So now we're only moving forward.
Even after returning from the
front line,
the troops continue to train,
assaulting enemy positions.
So important
for Ukraine's
ongoing major counter offensive.
The guys here say that the battles
that they've had with the Russians
have been extremely tough.
They've had to fight for every yard,
and yet they are confident,
they say, that they can make
this counteroffensive a success.
Troops
we spoke to say
the biggest threat to them is
Russian air power.
I'd like
this video
released by the Russian defense ministry
purporting to show a Russian attack
helicopter
hitting a Ukrainian armored vehicle.
The 128th deputy commander acknowledges
choppers, planes
and drones are making his forces
advance tougher.
Was put out too late then,
so they work continuously,
he says, all day long,
either with helicopters or with planes.
It's hard to advance like that,
but we retake territory.
We do not allow them to hit the columns.
And the unit says
they've managed to capture
not only territory,
but also hardware from the Russians,
including this infantry fighting vehicle.
Mechanics now
fixing it up to use against the Russians.
An angry Russian president
complaining about Kiev's
offensive and claiming
that Russia is beating back
Ukraine's forces, but
they've suffered large losses.
Vladimir Putin says
ten times more than the Russian army.
And that is a fact
The Ukrainians do
acknowledge some losses,
but also say they've taken out
a lot of Russian assets
and these troops
vow to press on
and take more vehicles
from Moscow's troops as they advance
So as you can see
there, Wolf, some serious
fighting going on on the southern
front line.
I have to say, though,
the forces that we spoke to today,
they were pretty upbeat
about the situation, upbeat.
The Ukrainians also about the situation
in the east of the country.
In fact,
they're saying that they're making
some pretty big gains
around the area of Bermuda.
They also say that the Russians are now
bringing some combat ready
forces into that area as well
to try and hold the Ukrainians up.
But the Ukrainians are saying
they are making some real gains around
Bermuda Wolf.
All right, Fred Pleitgen,
as Operation
in the war zone in Ukraine for us,
thank you.
Stay safe.
Oksana Merkava,
ambassador,
thank you so much for joining us.
How do you respond
to those nuclear threats
that we're hearing now?
Directly from Vladimir Putin?
Wolf, and thank you for having me.
Well, we have to just remind ourselves
that it is Ukraine
that got rid of a third nuclear
arsenal in 1994.
It is Ukraine
that was always peaceful
and it's Russia
that continuously is a threat of risk.
Not only military in Ukraine
and in the region,
but food security, energy security.
And at this point,
you know, again, as we said before,
we should remind an indicted
war criminal, Mr.
Putin, that instead of continuing
threaten and peaceful nations,
he should focus on actually
getting out
from Ukraine
where his troops performed
miserably and quit
when we conducted a number of war crimes,
including the massive shelling of Kiev
and problems today.
So on blowing up the Hoover Dam
and all the atrocities
that they have committed.
So yes,
it's it's another it's
to threaten all of us so that we stop
in defending democracy,
freedom and the values that we all share.
And we will not stop.
We will continue to liberate in Ukraine.
And I am positive
our friends will also not stop
in supporting Ukraine
as Ukraine
ambassador makes
what are being described
as incremental advances
in this new counteroffensive.
What would you say to some Western allies
waiting to see what they want to see,
namely major gains out there
on the battlefield?
We all knew
it's good
is that it's going to be very difficult.
You know, we the front
is very low on South
East of Ukraine.
Plus, again,
the fact that Russians blew up
the dam and flooded
the whole area
and saw not only devastation
dozens of villages and affected people,
but also making it difficult.
You know, but again,
regardless of how hard it is,
we have heard President Zelensky
loud and clear
and all the commanders,
we are making progress.
We will make progress.
Of course,
all of us
would like it
to be as fast as possible
because it's our people
who are suffering under occupation there.
And we have very high trust
in our commanders
and our brave defenders.
Regardless of how hard it is.
We will liberate all Ukraine.
Ambassador, CNN has learned
and I assume you know
this, that President Biden
is now willing
to drop one hurdle in Ukraine's push
to become a NATO member.
Is that small
step enough to deter Russia?
What do you think
I will only say that,
you know, Ukraine
has made our civilisational choice.
We would like to be a member
of the European Union,
and we're already candidate country
and we would like to be a member of NATO.
It's in our hearts.
It's in our Constitution.
It's something that not only the majority
of Ukrainians share and believe in,
but also it's
we believe that Ukraine has a lot
to add to later.
Now, how it will happen, it's for us
and all the NATO members to decide.
But I think, you know,
not only that Ukraine is ready
and willing to be part of
this family
of civilized countries, countries
that share the same values,
but we have done a lot of reforms and
have a lot to end But,
you know, again, as we all are
preparing for the summit,
of course, we will not go ahead and say,
you know,
the expectations, but we work a lot
with our friends and partners
and we really believe in that.
Ambassador Oksana Makarova.
Good luck to you, as I always tell you.
And good luck
to all the people of Ukraine.
Thanks so much for joining us.